il y a quelque chose de dangereux dans
l'ennui des adolescentes
la coach avait vu quelque chose en nous
au delà des paillettes des cheveux et de
notre attitude
elle avait vu ce qui se cachait dessous
[Musique]
nouvelle coach débarque en ville et elle
s'imagine qu'elle peut diriger mon
équipe
oui ils avaient leur thé non seul au
point que risquerait de faire la loi
vous devriez vous méfier de baisse
[Musique]
si tu veux mon avis il ya quelque chose
qui tourne pas rond chez cette cloche
tu voulais quoique je la laisse tomber
aujourd'hui vous êtes terrell dbs
faites-les s'incliner devant tout ce
qu'on fait on le fait avec intensité
désir fougue et en fin de compte
je ne pouvais rien empêché